right now though we want to go from
earthquakes to extreme heat as
temperatures are expected to climb into
the 80s in Alaska today that's actually
a slight dip from the record-breaking
90 degrees that made lakes and ponds a
go-to destination and broke records in
Anchorage and to other cities on the 4th
of July in the plains and all the way to
the Northeast the story is rain and
thunderstorms meteorologist Jeff Booher
Adelie can tell the story even better
and has more on the nation's weather
today Jeff good morning good morning
Dana good morning everybody so the big
weather story is they heat a big heat
Ridge but not record-breaking heat ridge
across parts of the southeast on its
northern extent we talked about the
threat for showers and storms and so
there will be a line of severe weather
in the Northeast we'll show you that on
future radar it'll start in places like
Buffalo and into Burlington Vermont and
make its way south through Albany
eventually Binghamton New York Boston
all the way down to Philadelphia and
Washington DC so watch out for hail
strong wind gusts obviously heavy
downpours as well
the bigger story the next several days
the heat in the southeast feels like
temperatures about 100 to 105 degrees
it'll actually get worse and build over
the next couple of days feels like 105
in Houston on Sunday on Monday across
the southeast 106 as it feels like
temperature in Pensacola hundred in
Dallas all right let's show you what's
happening across the United States and
then kind of pull out the Pacific Ocean
talk about a convoluted jet stream flow
this is what's causing this major heat
wave in Alaska we have a record-breaking
heat Ridge we got 290 degrees a couple
of days ago in Anchorage that broke an
all-time record by 5 degrees so this is
a heat wave on steroids let's show you
how hot it's going to be today and a lot
of folks once again above that 80 degree
mark today and it looks like it may even
be hotter tomorrow with high
temperatures in Fairbanks somewhere
around 90 degrees it's just amazing it's
been over 80 degrees five days in a row
in Anchorage that breaks a summer record
and we're not even at the beginning of
some we're barely at the beginning of
the summer right now when you think
Alaska you don't think heat waves don't
what why is this happening right now
so water temperatures are about 10 to 18
degrees above normal right now Arctic
sea ice is it
levels in fact since 1979 this is an
unbelievable stat we have lost it has
melted by 50% the Arctic sea ice and
this is a thermostat for the rest of the
earth so when that changes fundamentally
it changes steering patterns all over
the world and it spikes extreme weather
it takes an ordinary extreme event and
makes it an extraordinary extreme event
heat waves like France and also flooding
in the Midwest so you talk about it
affecting other places around the world
what does it mean for us what does it
mean for for people in this country yeah
so it has a cascading effect everything
is connected in the atmosphere in the
ocean so if you change something
fundamentally there it kind of runs
downstream and can cause these extreme
perturbations in the jet stream we have
them right now and that's likely to get
worse in the future this is all the
climate change that you keep talking to
us about and it's happening fast ok Jeff
thanks very much